the way I do it it doesn't happen for me  spontaneously I might say I may have  discovered inadvertently I have to  invoke it sort of in fact not sort of I  just invoke it and I feel somewhat  embarrassed to do that because it's such  a weird thing to do but I do and I even  speak to it and say usually what I say  is something like show and I call it  thing because our relationship is  informal and I say show thing show what  you know show and it will begin to show  and then I say what you show is  beautiful thing show more and it's just  like coaxing something out but it never  steps back you know once you get it  coaxed out it's there and it is it is  fully active